هنا شارع صلاح الدين شمال مدخل مخيم
البريج والنصيرات
هذه
المنطقه تعرضت ل قصف من قبل دبابات
الاحتلال وطائرات
الاحتلال هذا الشارع الان شارع صلاح الدين
وهذا المدخل هو مدخل محطه الكهرباء وسط
قطاع غزه شمال
النصيرات دمار كبير
في المصانع
والبركسات بركس بكرون للاخشاب
معصره ابو عوده هنا الدمار الكبير في هذه
المعصره والتي كانت تخدم قطاع غزه بشكل
كامل من شماله حتى جنوبه ياتي
هنا اهل القطاع لعصر
الزيتون دمرت بشكل
كامل
عمارات سكنيه لعائله اللوح قد دمرت بشكل
وكذلك مصنع الواديه هذا المصنع لم يفتتح
بعد هنا مصنع زمرد ايضا و يعني حمد
للاخشاب
وهذه السكنه التي كانت ماوى لدبابات
الاحتلال مصنع زمرد هنا للرخام والجرانيت
ايضا هذا
المنزل يسمى قصر اللوح تم تدميره بشكل
كامل الان نحن على جسر وادي غزه الجسر
الرابط ما بين شمال القطاع وجنوبه وصلنا
لهذا المنطقه رغم تحليق طرات الاحتلال
لاننا سنرصد
لكم اثار عدوان الاحتلال وقصف الاحتلال
وتدميره
ل منازل
المواطنين يعني هذا بئر للمياه جمعيه
الامه الخيريه تم تدمير هذا البئر بشكل
كامل مسجد النور
مساجد دمرت بشكل كامل هذا هو مسجد النور
يعني دور العباده لم تسلم من قصف الاحتلال
حتى المباني التي لم يتم تدميرها تم حرقها
بشكل
كامل كما نشاهد في هذا المبنى
حيث تم احراقه بشكل
كامل هنا مدخل شارع الدعوه هذا المدخل هو
في المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه لمخيم
النصيرات الدمار الكبير الذي احل بهذه
المنطقه بعد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال والياته
وجرافات
يعني هذا يعني هذه الحقول الزراعيه التي
كانت بها اشجار
زيتون جرفت بشكل
كامل تم تجريف هذه المنطقه بشكل
كامل
وتدمير لكافه الحقول
والاشجار المثمره بالزيتون
والحمضيات تم تدميرها بشكل كامل هي شمال
شرق مخيم
النصيرات
ما تعرف بارض القصين مقابل محطه شركه
الكهرباء